لم يُشاهد زعيم داعش أبو بكر البغدادي
منذ خمس سنوات حتى
الآن نشاهد لقطات تظهر له
أنه تم إصدارها اليوم على ما يبدو مما أدى إلى
إلغاء بعض التقارير عن
إصابته الخطيرة وحتى وفاته على مدار سنوات
في الفيديو.
- على الأرض بجوار
مدفع رشاش ، دعا إلى الانتقام
بعد سقوط آخر بلدة كانت تحت سيطرة داعش
في سوريا من قبل Goo ، كما أنه حان الوقت
للإشارة إلى هجمات سريلانكا على CNN ،
كلاريسا وارد ، مراسلنا الدولي الرئيسي
ينضم إلي الآن مع المزيد  في
هذا الخبر العاجل ، ما الذي يجب أن
نأخذه من هذا الفيديو الذي
نشرته الذراع الإعلامية لداعش ، أعتقد أنني
أردت فقط الإدلاء ببيان جريء
هنا ، حسنًا ، يأتي هذا في أعقاب
الهزيمة المطلقة
لخلافتهم المادية لأراضيهم في  سوريا في
العراق يريدون إرسال رسالة مفادها
أنهم أقوياء بأنهم قادرون على التكيف
حتى يتمكنوا من النجاة
من انهيار الخلافة وهكذا بعد
هجمات سريلانكا نحن  شاهد هذا الآن
أبو بكر البغدادي لأول مرة
كما قلت منذ ما يقرب من خمس سنوات
عند ظهوره على الكاميرا وما
الفرق الذي جعلته هذه السنوات الخمس
ترى اختلافًا حقيقيًا في
مظهره الجسدي ، فمن الواضح أنه
اكتسب الكثير من الوزن.  لحيته شديدة
البياض على الرغم من وجود حناء على أطرافها
، وقال إنه اخترق الهدوء الشديد أثناء حديثه
طوال هذا الفيديو ، ويبدو
أنه يُظهر هالة من السلطة أو على
الأقل يحاول الظهور أو
السلطة التي شاهدها جالسًا على
الأرض يتحدث إلى  يقوم العديد من الرجال بالاطلاع على
ملفات ولاية مختلفة أو
ولايات مختلفة حيث يوجد لداعش
مؤيدون لديهم ملفات
لليبيا من أجل المؤتمرات الحزبية ومن الواضح
أن الرسالة هي أنك قد تعتقد
أننا قُتلنا وقد قال العديد من الناس أننا
قتلني  قُتلت على
وجه التحديد في الماضي لكننا ما زلنا
هنا وما زلت على قيد الحياة